one of our favorite guests in the near
six year history of the show
loved meeting him in person when he was
here in studio as well
and uh as good a human as he is a major
league baseball player
currently raking uh at a particular clip
that is very impressive and uh he's from
the colorado rockies he's charlie
blackman here on the show how are you
charlie
hey welch thanks for having me i did not
mention your average are you one of
those players that doesn't want to talk
about your statistics
because you're a little surprised
some weird stuff that i do and one of
them is i try my best
when things are going good not to look
at the scoreboard or look for the
numbers
i pretty much only look at the numbers
when they stink well because i remember
one of my colleagues
um on espn uh who i was name i won't
mention
uh once mentioned to paul o'neill during
the 2000 world series just how hot he
was he was six for his last 10 and paul
nearly walked away from the interview he
was so pissed
that the statistics you mentioned live
like that i hate it especially when it
comes to
like hitting streaks which right you
know i had one last week whatever it's
over now
back to normal but i don't like when
people
either state the obvious or you know you
just don't talk about something while
it's happening you know like wait till
afterwards and then be like hey you were
really good you know
back then um i just
it's baseball such a mental game that
like
if you let it get to you be like wow
maybe i am like you know
really feeling it right now that's like
the death of it can't have it can't have
that so do you even stay away from like
meatloaf songs like two out of three
ain't bad do you even stay away from
stuff like
you're that that crazy okay so what do
you do what what is what is part of the
the whole charlie blackman making sure
everything uh goes right
type of uh regimen that you got going on
what do you do
or do you don't even like talking about
that is that is that even a problem
no no that's i just you know i try and
stay in my little bubble like stay in my
lane
okay and uh you know try and know that
i'm doing everything i need to be doing
you know like
scouting and practicing and just putting
myself in a good place mentally
where you know like i don't have
anything to worry about
um and then of course i i try and stay
away from
the media as much as i
accommodating um do you do because i you
know i've been around so many great
uh athletes been fortunate enough to
work with some
um dion sanders always used to
always used to lay out his uniform on on
the
on the floor before putting it on so
you'd imagine greatness
i will throw terrell davis under the bus
he would take a bubble bath the night
before
always would have to do stuff like that
do you have that
charlie i i don't i i don't have
anything
that i think is is weird like that uh i
do
just try and keep things in perspective
like every time that i go out on the
field
i need to be thankful for the
opportunity to be there right
you know a lot of things have to go
right i have to be
young healthy and pretty good at
baseball in order to be able to play in
a big
game so if my mind is right there that's
a pretty good start and the second thing
is
when i go out there i have a chance to
do something great every day
and that's just kind of readying the
mechanism you know like if my mind is in
the right place
good things can happen uh usually
doesn't you know
usually your your average or mediocre
but that's when
you know that's what makes a great day
uh
so special charlie blackman who did have
the uh meatloaf stat line if you will
two out of three for two runs better
than yesterday and that's the only
statistics i will mention here in this
interview right here on the rich eisen
show with the
the rocky center fielder all right let's
get into it what is it like running out
on the field right now no fans
middle of covert 19 protocols all over
the place what is it like for you
right now charlie um at first it was
really different
um but i'll say this like baseball
players
can get used to almost anything if they
do it enough
right like guys keep throwing harder and
harder and harder but like you still
can't throw a fastball by some of these
guys
you know if you see it enough you can
make that your new normal
um and so our new normal is really weird
compared to
last year um but the one thing i will
take away from it is it's just
it's a super intimate game now if you
have the opportunity to like
tune in you should check it out like
it's there's there's no like ambient
noise
you know when when our third baseman
aaron arnotto makes a great play i'm
like hey nolan but you know great play
and he can look back like thanks you
know like it's weird that he can hear me
all the way across the field um it's
just super intimate you got your you
know your teammates are the only people
screaming
and i mean it's it's it's more like
you're just playing for your teammates
instead of um instead of for the fans
which
you know everything should be about the
fans but if there's one thing that's
you know also important it's it's the
teammates you're playing for of course
and then and you know staying healthy
for your teammates uh and doing the
right thing to do that
uh is important and i want to get to
that in a second
do you want to get to you first um you
did get
coveted 19 and i have do you have any
lingering effects
of of having had coven 19 charlie
rick i think i'm a hundred percent
recovered i
i wouldn't chalk anything that i'm
feeling up to
a lasting effect from
the copa virus and you know i'm lucky to
be in that position
but my experience of the virus was that
it wasn't
that bad but i know that there's
not everybody is young and in pretty
good shape and going to bounce back as
quickly as i have
um so you know i
i feel like based on my experience it
was tough
to see how much our culture has changed
to dodge this virus
but you know based on other people's
experience that kind of makes it
a little bit
[Music]
makes me understand why we're we're
changing so much because it can be so
dangerous because it can
not do that what is what do you mean by
dodging it and and the difficulty and
what do you mean by that what you said a
minute ago
like i felt sick for a couple days right
and i you know i think it's
you know if it was up to me i wish i
could have got it you know at the
beginning of spring training and then we
just had a normal baseball season
um but not everybody's experience is
going to be like that right like
you can't just assume that everybody's
going to bounce back and be okay
uh you do have to you know prepare
and try your best to keep the at-risk
people
healthy and safe charlie blackman of the
colorado rockies here on the rich eisen
show so are you how how often are you
guys
being tested are you different because
you've had it or what what
what's that about walk me through your
your protocol
our protocols are pretty strict and
they're getting even more strict because
we've had a few
positives pop up but we test at least
every other day
and they're doing a good job of getting
that those tests turned around very
quickly
and then i mean we're we're wearing
masks
everywhere except for like when you're
actively eating or drinking in which
case you're
socially distant or you're on the field
playing the game
you pretty much have to wear a mask
everywhere they have masked police
walking around the locker room that
have to you know like their only job is
to like make sure that you're wearing
your mask
uh you know a lot of what i do to
prepare for the game is changing like i
can't scout like i used to scout i used
to go in there and sit on the computer
and you know pull up all the database
like you can't do that anymore
no no communal computer stations you
know i have to do it all from
like my personal ipad
they've made it more difficult in the
training room uh
you know everybody's wearing gloves they
have to if you get in the hot tank
on the road now the hot tanks are
usually like a one
like one big tub right for one person if
you get in the hot or cold tank and you
get out they have to like drain all the
water out
fill it right back up i mean we're doing
our best to try and keep everybody
safe do you feel safe i
honestly i feel safe like if you're
asking me
you know i i'm not trying to make a huge
statement about opting out or anything
like that
but i do know that i feel
very safe you know here with these
protocols and all this testing
um and having a highly trained medical
staff like taking care of me
i feel probably more safe you know here
doing what i'm doing
rather than you know at home when i was
at home it was
i was struggling to find a place to test
you know i was struggling to get in
front of
someone who wasn't associated with the
team that could help me medically
in this situation so i i feel really
safe
well what's the conversation that you're
charlie blackman here on the rich hyzer
show what's the conversation you and
your teammates are having with each
other about
being smart once you're out of the
facility and not going anywhere or
breaking protocol
in a manner in which it appears two
members of the cleveland indians did
jeff pass into espn reporting
so many uh a bunch of indians are are so
uh
upset uh that they um
they made sure that these players were
optioned out so i'm wondering what's the
conversation you're having about staying
strong for each other and healthy for
each other and smart
yeah we i mean we got together very
early and got
uh we basically everybody had a voice we
decided hey like what do we want to do
as a team
what's important to us uh and we decided
number one the most important thing is
that we want we want baseball to be
played right like we think we have a
good team we want to
we want a chance to go to the postseason
we want to play baseball um
so we you know we started making some
team rolls like hey this is what we're
going to do
the best way to make sure that this
baseball played is that nobody gets
you know and so we started um making
these rules you know no going out
uh you know you know like i can't bring
my people
on the road you know like i can't have
people getting
you know going through the airport
riding on a plane showing up in la when
we're there to play and then i hang out
you know we're not going to do any of
that kind of stuff we're going to do
what we need to do to play
and that's pretty much stay in your
bubble right go to the field
play the game come back and either be
with your family who's been quarantined
with
the whole time or you know be by
yourself and that's
i mean that's not only to keep us able
to play baseball but like
if if we got guys going out and getting
sick
and we do shut things down like you're
gonna take a paycheck away from
everybody who's worked really hard you
know to get to this level and only have
a
short window to to capitalize monetarily
on on that hard work i mean it's it can
be pretty serious
and i don't think it should be taken
lightly uh people that aren't
uh trying to be on the same page with
everybody else
but this is a conversation you and your
colleagues had with each other right
um oh yeah yeah this isn't nobody forced
this on us
right i mean they told us you know i
mean there's rules right but this came
from within this is organic
people you know we want to see this
season
uh complete it you know like we want to
see what we can do
and so we kind of implemented these
measures amongst ourselves
too charlie i'll tell you what man i
know last we spoke you know you were
talking about i want to play and i hope
the politics stay out of it and
unfortunately we saw what did happen but
the fact that you're back
i'm loving it i'm watching it with my
kids i'm i'm as into it
as as ever and you know i
being in a position like the one that i
am in um
hear some uh folks saying well it's only
60 games whatever
i think the winner of this season the
banner should be bigger because of
everything that is going on i mean and
and what you
i'm wondering what you feel going
through this
um as a player and what what it would
mean for a colorado rockies
world series championship out of a
season like this charlie
um you know i think
i think there's yeah there's a couple
different ways to look at it right it's
not as many
not as many games uh there's you know
weird crazy circumstances
but i do know that the people that want
it the most
are the people that continue to prepare
even when spring training got suspended
you know like kept going to the yard
kept working hard
kept their body in shape and
and really wanted the game to happen
like those are the people that are going
to succeed
you know especially this season um
there's a lot of people that maybe
weren't there mentally like
didn't want it you know like you didn't
continue to work those are the people
that are going to get beat
uh or get you know unfortunately some
people get
are getting hurt um you know and i don't
want to blame the people that are
getting hurt on that they weren't
working hard like it was a very
quick ramp up but but i still think like
you're seeing
like the competitive desire come out
from these guys
and everybody has a chance to make it to
the playoffs i mean
i still think it's a very competitive
season uh i do think
also we've changed the playoff format so
that more teams will make it
so we've addressed that short season to
allow more teams into the playoffs
so i do think like you're going to have
to really earn it if you want this world
series you're going to have to play
multiple series in the playoffs against
good teams
to get there i mean i just i think it's
really exciting and i can't wait for
the next month or two me too man and i
just love it how you say that you're
it's so quiet in the park that you know
your teammates hear each other
i imagine though um the umpires can hear
what you're saying a little bit easier
too
charlie yes no that's uh yeah that's
been been an issue already uh
you know like i've i've spent a lot of
time in the dugout i kind of you know
operate in the same way once there's
fans in the stands or not
it's it's kind of ingrained and when
certain calls are made you're like
i can only see like how high or how low
the ball is
and when there's a ball that's called a
strike and one of my teammates is
hitting and it's too low
like the first words out of my mouth are
that's too low and it's really really
loud
well usually the umpire can't hear you
or you can
pretend like he's not hearing you but
now it's like it's almost like uh
you know you personally offended him and
so it's like he he hears it so loud and
clear he like has to look over
and then he's like oh it's blackman
there like i can see him on the top step
looking straight at me i mean it's i'm
surprised we haven't had more
issues um yeah and you know it's it's
tough for those guys too because they
kind of ramped up quick you know
of course uh it's just
the communication level like baseball is
not a great
sport of communication well the
communication level's gone way up this
year you know with no fans in the stands
you can hear
a lot more right yeah you can hear it
right and then uh and then even the
bench clearing moments
you know everybody kind of i guess tries
to maintain a social distant
um bench clearing situation what did you
think of those
that we saw recently charlie you know i
wouldn't even know what to do
uh i mean yeah guys are playing hard
it's you know it's still a very
emotional game
and you're going to get fired up about
things and
and honestly you know there's a point to
which like if you boil over that edge
you're not caring about you're
distancing
and that's what happened and i hope we
don't have any negative
uh you know consequences from that
but you know you don't like to see it it
is very exciting
i'm not gonna lie like i love watching
it when things like that happen
you do you do so so did you when you
were watching the joe kelly
uh you know uh hit-a-thon that that and
then
and then that look that he gave the
astros you kind of you
you kind of liked that one uh
loved it i mean let me back up let me
back up okay
like even if people deserve to get hit
which i think
should happen sometimes like i'll say it
you you can't throw up people's heads
like you can't
do it like that's gonna really hurt
people right you know if you're trying
to hit him in the hip
and you still and it sailed up by their
head your fault
like you should be punished um
but at the same time like you know i'm
i think the game's getting younger and i
don't want
her but like the new school is very
different than
old school and you've got a little bit
of both playing the game right now and
sometimes it doesn't mix very well
and uh you know i think joe kelly tried
to lay down the law i think it's
i think it's great uh i i wish you know
some of those pitches hadn't been up by
somebody's head right
um and you know what like for him to
make a look at the dugout
like that like i think that's just way
better than
seeing a bunch of f words i'm gonna have
to bleep out and i can't let my kids
watch it you know like that's
uh a little more wholesome to me somehow
well he did
he did give kind of a school yard sort
of you know pouty face sort of like you
know go cry to mom yeah i think that's
what he kind of gave that was
the vibe that i picked up he once again
the communication has increased this
year he communicated
very well he did a great job
of letting the outros know just how he
felt and i think everybody else
they did pick up on that charlie you're
correct hey charlie i love our chats i
really do and greatly appreciate i don't
know you don't uh
do it a lot and uh just another reason
to wear a mask is if you're chirping it
blue
you know he won't know it's you you just
if you're a loud talker
if you're learning that you're a loud
talker now based on everything that's
going on just wear that mask he cannot
tell
blue will not be able to tell you're
telling them it's too low if you're if
you're massed up you know
yeah that's true it's another benefit
just another benefit thanks for the time
charlie let's chat again real soon
really appreciate it
thanks rich right back at you the one
and only charlie blackman
hi babe how do you not like that guy one
and only charlie blackman
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here